you guys want to hear something
absolutely insane I was able to take
home more than a year than the CEOs of
McDonald's Ikea Ford Motorola and
Yahoo
combined as a kid in his
20s and I have continued to for over
half a
decade which results in a $200 million
pre-year portfolio and $100 million net
worth by age 32 and no one is more
surprised than me me expressing that
fact will create Envy in some anger in
others skepticism in most confusion in
old people and Inspire select few you
are who I made this presentation for but
before I dive in raise your hand if
you'd like any of the following things
to happen to be able to charge two times
five times 10 times more than your
competition for the exact same thing
like Yeti We have basically identical
cups and somehow they're able to charge
$40 versus $10 simply because of what on
the cup if you'd like to be able to have
customers buy from you over and over and
over again without considering
competition like Harley once you're a
Harley guy you stay a Harley guy for
life and if you'd like to virtually
guarantee sales in any new business or
product that you launch like apple a lot
of people just weit and lie they say
just leave my credit card just bill me
and send whatever you're going to come
out with and that's more or less how a
lot of Apple buyers are once they become
an apple person they become an apple
person for life
so if you like that stuff great because
that's what this talk is about and so I
couldn't figure out how these Brands
these companies were able to do this
demand these prices get people to stay
loyal for a really long
time and I felt like for me I always had
to like big borrow and steal and I had
to squeeze and push so hard just to get
people to buy whereas these companies
made it look
effortless and it's because I didn't
understand this one thing and that's the
subject of the talk today
brand and the thing is even people who
claim to understand it often don't and
the few who do understand it do a
terrible job teaching it so this
definitely is going to be marketing
oneon-one class on branding presentation
colors and logos and this definitely
isn't going to be about feelings
presence Intuition or whatever this is
about making
money and this concept that I'm going to
explain to you is How I build a 7.8
million person audience
across all these Platforms in the past
40 months or so I sold over a million
copies of my last two books and your
deals worth hundreds of million doll in
our holding Cy
acquisition. that is why you build a
brand or at least that's why I built
mine and so today I'm going to cover
three things number one what branding is
you don't know what it is you certainly
can't build one number two why it makes
money because once you have it built
you're like okay well how do I trade
this thing for doll hairs which is what
we want and then third how to start and
grow yours so let's start with the first
one what branding is so when I decided
to build a brand I looked at what many
popular marketers said about it here are
some popular definitions that I have
removed the marketers from them this is
not throwing shade so I'm just saying
them a brand is a person's gut feeling
about a product service or organization
a brand is not what you say it is it's
what they say it is a brand is a set of
expectations memories stories and
relations to that take it together
account for a customer's decision to
choose one product or service over
another a brand is emotional shorthand
for accumulated and assumed information
a brand is present with the value of
what the product service or personality
means to its audience is greater than
what it does for the audience a brand is
a product service or concept that is
publicly distinguished from other
product services or concepts so it can
be easily communicated and usually
marketed branding is the process of
creating and disseminating the brand
name its qualities and personality the
promotion of a particular product or
Company by means of advertising and
distinctive design if these sound vague
and confusing it's because they
are and I was just as confused as you
when I was trying to figure this out
because none of them told me what to do
and so after looking at all these
marketers words I think I pieced it
together at least enough that once I
started thinking about this way in a
different way I'm about to share with
you my brand grew and it grew fast and
the reason this is so important is that
if you don't know what to do nothing's
going to change fundamentally if you
don't change your behavior obviously
nothing's going to change as result
and so I want to Def find this one term
before we get going
learning who here came to learn raise
your hands fantastic all other words
just being talking to the wall so
learning means same condition new
behavior and so if I wanted to teach
someone a phone script then after
teaching you the phone rings again and
you say the new script you learned
learning occurred on the other hand if I
tried to teach you the script and then
the phone Rings again and then you
change nothing no learning occurred you
learned
nothing and that's why none of this
stuff that these guys said helped me
because I didn't know what I could do I
didn't know what Behavior I had to
change as a result of
this so I didn't know how to do it and
so here's how branding happens branding
is a deliberate pairing of
things through an outcome so I'll say
that again bring is a deliberate pairing
of things through an out cup so let's
use Coca-Cola drinking it and liking it
as our example the Yum aka the outcome
that's what people get they pair that
with drinking the action so what they do
to get it with Coca-Cola the
product so the next time you want some
yum you're probably going to reach
for a Coca-Cola if that was paired for
you
successfully and so branding is a
deliberate pairing of things through an
outcome that's it but sometimes
businesses pair stuff pair their stuff
with things that people don't
like that's bad
branding this leads to losses for the
business now some of you guys may have
seen this this is Dylan mulany doing a
collaboration with Bud Light there's a
lot of press around this
advertisement this advertisement was
actually a great advertisement and you
might might think I'm crazy but it was
let me explain it's just not the way you
might think it was this is a great
advertisement because it let a lot of
people know about their stuff it let a
lot of people know about the product
about Bud
Light by the way if you're curious that
is the definition of advertising not
branding advertising is letting people
know about your stuff branding is the
pairing that occurs as a result so it
was good advertising but bad
branding many customers hated this
pairing lots of people found out but a
lot of people hated it good advertising
bad branding
and so as a result of this bad branding
people not liking the pairing fewer
people bought the product which netted a
loss for the
business and so to fix this budl paired
the product with stuff the audience
liked like Shane Gillis who is a man's
man comedian and the UFC a man's man of
sports if you will and sales began to
recover so that's the oneone explanation
of branding let's go into
2011 so to go a little deeper because
the better you get at this the more
money you will make like the more Nuance
you can understand how to brand and
build a brand for yourself the more
money you will make I promise you that
and so to some people the dill m m
pairing was actually good in general
both good advertising and good branding
hear me out for others it was bad
obviously all pairings have positive and
negative results and that's because
everyone's different everyone has
different
preferences but for a business you can
objectively see if a pairing was good or
bad whether it netted you more
money so more people disliked the
Dyan tough date Dyan M pairing so SES
suffered making it a bad pairing so this
isn't opinion they objectively made less
money and so this pairing was a bad for
their ideal audience now the 301 version
of this is is there a company or a
product where the D vany pairing could
have been both good advertising and good
branding so that the majority of people
would have bought I think the answer is
yes it just doesn't necessarily mean
it's Bud Light for conservative males as
the primary
audience and on the other hand some
people love the new Gillis and UFC
pairings and some hated it but more of
the audience that is their ideal
customer liked it saw it as good and so
the business netted sales a result and
they made more money good
branding and so for Budweiser and I just
want to call this out this is
specifically for Budweiser in their
customer base it's not that Shen gillers
so the UFC is Magic in some way or Dylan
mulany is unmagic in some way but for
that specific audience yes the pairing
mattered and how much of the base liked
it or disliked
it so if you're anything like me making
money is the point so let's drive this
home if you made a pairing of your thing
and your customer and you got to choose
which outcome you had happen so you have
your product and they drink it there's
an outcome that happens afterwards right
that pairs with it on one hand 75% like
it and 25 hate it or on the other hand
25% like it and 75% hate it which would
be the bottom
example which would you
choose more money good the big the big
green one yes of course the top one
because it would make you the most
money and so to be clear for the 2011
level of understanding branding always
happens branding always
occurs but our goal is good
branding and good branding is a
deliberate pairing of our business with
good outcomes for our ideal
customers and so what you pair your
business with determines two key things
one who pays attention to your business
and two whether they go towards your
business like the UFC example or away
from a business like the Del Mia
example and so at the beginning of this
I said I was going to cover three things
the first thing I said is what is
branding but now that we have gone
through that I want to resay what I
walked us through which is what good
branding is ideally what we're shooting
for so now that we covered that let's
talk about why it makes you money why
good branding makes you money branding
as I to find it happens everywhere all
the time but businesses use it for
profit so let's look at some of the
earliest uses of branding to figure out
how we can use it so these are the first
entrepreneurs who use branding to make
money the earliest version of branding
that we can think of or at least that I
can think of happened on livestock it
was literally a brand they would heat up
metal they'd sear it into the side of a
cattle and they would get a lovely
little logo maybe we'll have a Nike
Swoosh cow someday and so they literally
burn these symbols into animals and
those symbols had a magical effect
so let's say you're walking around and
you see a cow with no bread you say
hello cow the cow says move back and it
has nothing on it this is just a cow you
might leave it
alone and that might be it on the other
hand let's say the cow has a bread you
recognize say it's your neighbors you
might be like hey that's Bill's cow now
if you like Bill you might grab the cow
and pull him by the whatever you pull
cows by and probably return it to Bill
if you hate bill then the cow may stay
lost in the wilderness forever and
become lunch for your family for the
next month or two in the form of
delicious
burgers but either way For Better or For
Worse the brand affected what you did it
affected your
behavior and so to take this to the 2011
level what if you see a branded cow but
you don't recognize the brand you might
be like who this I see a logo but I
don't know anything about it well then
you would treat it how you treat braided
animals in general in that you just know
that it belongs to someone and so you
would treat it the way that you treat it
as though it belong to anybody
else and even if only a tiny bit you
would treat a wild cow different from a
branded cow in general so if you had one
that was wild and you had one that you
didn't recognize but was branded you
would still probably treat them
differently so that just shows you the
power of brand as a concept because it
dictates a tie between that c in a human
being or some complex animal that can
brand
cow and so these are all effects of
brand in general so that's how affects
what people do and so now I want to get
tactical on how to get how we translate
that concept into getting them to buy so
let's say we pair our brand so this is
where we get really tactial and this is
like okay if you don't have a brand this
is the step by step right now so you
have a weak brand and we say it's a weak
brand because it's starting up you don't
have really a lot of Association
fantastic so now you want to pair with
people experiences other C other stuff
that your ideal customer likes so in
this instance I'm using little Nike
pairing with LeBron and tiger who are
Champions World Class goats Etc and so
people who like sports and competition
would see that probably as a positive
pairing AKA good stuff and so if we do
that pairing or we make that pairing for
the majority of people braining will
occur and so the brand
grows and so the question then follows
what's the benefit of a strong brand
versus a weak
brand and so the the the weak brand is
before the pairing the stronger brand is
after the pairing so a strong brand
turns commoditized products like a $5
white T-shirt plus the strong brand into
a premium product a higher value brand
name
product and preium products with a
strong
brand then get customers to want to pair
themselves with the product so that they
can associate the outcome
themselves with the outcome the brand
delivers which they do with their money
so how do they make that Association
they give money they get the shirt the
association happens based on what
they've seen where that logo has been
elsewhere and so then they go from I
want to be a winner to exchanging money
and saying now I am a winner or I feel
like a winner that's how this works and
so this means that if the ideal customer
likees boards winning and competition
Etc then they're more likely to buy
stuff from a brand paired with those
things
so let's lay it all out weak brand
paired with stuff customers like creates
a strong brand strong brand gets put
onto a winning product transforms a
generic to winning product then the
customers want to associate with that
winning product so they buy the product
and they put money into your bank
account in order to do it and so as long
as you net a positive between what it
cost you to associate with tiger and
LeBron and how many t-shirts you can
sell a result you make
money and so here are some steps in
words for those of you who are more word
people you start with a brand that means
nothing you have a logo just like the
cow that the other person didn't
recognize people know that it is a brand
they just don't know what that brand
means yet so it means nothing right now
then you pair that brand with something
or someone that your customers ideally
like third your brand starts to mean the
thing customer likes to
them then they want to associate
themselves with that thing they like or
get more of
it but they can't buy that thing but
they can buy a tiny sliver of that
Association so they buy the shirt with
the logo that means that thing to them
and so they get the shirt you get the
money and it all happened because you
deliberately paired it with something
they
like and this happens everywhere so DOL
and gabana classic example they paired
with Kim Kardashian they made a line
specifically for her and so for a lady
who wants to associate with Fame Beauty
wealth that would be a pairing that
makes sense and so that lady who wants
other people to associate her with Fame
high class money luxury wealth will then
buy DOL and gabana and be like I'm just
like him now she might not say that
directly because she might just
associate with the values but the
transfer still
happens and so when someone looks at two
products that on the surface are
generically the same you've got two
T-shirts one that has a weak brand or no
brand and the other that has the strong
brand the person that has the strong
brand they're going to be more likely to
buy and pay more
for and this happens because they
actually buy the elements that we've
deliberately paired with the brand which
they identify
with and at this point of building a
brand you do this to change customer
behavior and that excuse me that is the
point of building a brand to change
customer Behavior in your favor when
they see it with a
product and so this is a quote from
warff that I like a lot kind of
signifying some of the elements of the
benefits of brand is that the single
most important decision in evaluating
business is pricing power if you've got
the power to raise prices without losing
business to a competitor you've got a
very good business and if you have to
have a prayer session before raising the
price by 10% then you've got a terrible
business and so if we have an unbred
t-shirt for $5 and we say you know what
we think we have a strong enough brand
that we can raise the price
and then boom we can raise the price and
still not lose that many sales but we in
this case 12x the price good branding
drives that premium
pricing good branding also improves
advertising so with the generic brand if
you're marketing this white T-shirt you
might get half a percent of people there
are many white t-shirts there are many
like it this one is mine just kidding so
the point for those of you got the
reference um so if you have a 05%
cluther rate on some that's generic
there's nothing special about it on the
flip side if you have a Nike bread
t-shirt same identical t-shirt and it
has the swoosh now you might get six
times as many people to click and buy at
a higher price see how these things
stack together that is why these Brands
exist for such a long period of time and
make so much money so they get cheaper
customers they get higher returns and
they have better response rates and
advertising and on top of that if if as
if that weren't enough good branding ALS
what drives Customer Loyalty AKA they
buy more stuff more times and so like
the Apple example I gave earlier once
you buy one Apple product you tend to
buy more and you tend to keep buying
them and so this also a good brand also
protects your business from competitors
stealing that customer in the
future and so as I promised in the
beginning who's seeing how this all this
stuff allows you to one be able to
charge 10 times or more than your
competition two get higher returns and
advertising so you can scale that much
more that much faster
and then three get people to keep buying
for Life compounding your money making
skills for good okay which is why
building a brand will make you lots of
money it's also why Brands outperform
Commodities in every single
industry and give a lasting competitive
advantage that to be fair is Theirs to
lose so here's another quote from Uncle
warrant it takes 20 years to build a
reputation and 5 minutes to ruin it if
you think about that you'll do things
differently and so so I said that I was
going to cover three things one what
branding is which we renamed what good
branding is second why it makes you
money think we got that so now let's go
to how to start or grow your own
brand so branding is the deliberate
pairing of things your thing plus what
your ideal customer has through an
outcome and good branding is the Del
paing of your thing with something
good to start a brand we have to know
what we want to pair it with to attract
ideal customers so here we've got light
UFC good outcome for the majority of the
audience and we want to understand that
just as much as we should also
understand which to avoid pairing our
brand with to lose customers like the D
Mia example and so here's how I like to
think about assembling the pairings for
a brand so if you're a ground zero you
have you have no brand you've got these
elements that haven't been put together
yet so I think about it
like a table full of flowers so if you
want to put it bouquet together you
start by having lots of different
flowers all over the
place on their own those flowers are not
a bouquet just as products values
experiences people Etc on their own are
not a
brand the flowers are like the brand
elements that we pair with stuff or
audiences
like with enough pairing over and over
and over again they form a
bouquet now replace the word bouquet
with
brand and so that assembly is the
connection it's the association between
those things because the brand
fundamentally doesn't actually exist if
I take the flowers out of the vase and
scatter them across was there ever a
brand to begin with it's simply the
association we make between those things
that creates the oneof one
brand and if we unravel it the brand
disappears and so the deliberate pairing
of those things makes the brand and if
we want to get narrower on our brand so
let's say I talk about tacos lifting and
philosophy if I want to narrow my brand
I'll just talk a bunch about tacos and
then all of my flowers are just Taco
related if I'm only talking about tacos
but I want to expand the stuff I'm
talking about to my audience and maybe
capture a wider audience then I might
talk about tacos quesadillas burritos
things that are tangential and then if I
wanted to expand even broader I might
just talk about food in general and then
I might talk in alcohol then I might
talk in restaurants and then things that
go wider and wider from there and so we
get narrower as we Niche down and we go
double down on one type of topic and we
go broader when we Branch
out but distant and random pairings hurt
a brand because they're so hard to make
the associations
with and this is what most brands are
and
do most people's Brands happen by
accident it's just whatever they appear
next to whatever people associate their
stuff with good branding happens on
purpose because like what are we looking
at with a a bike a single flow some
socks and a burger not a lot not a lot
to hold together there and so think
about it like curating a garden you want
some flowers to grow and you want to
pull out the weeds you have to do both
you have to add the good and take away
the bad in order to assemble the ideal
brand for
you and in the beginning our brand won't
be strong just like yours one if you're
building it then you might only have a
couple flowers there and it's because
you have haven't had that many instances
to pair your brand for that
customer but the more good stuff we pair
with our brand for the customer the
stronger it gets you go from one flower
to many red flowers or many red roses
that become a bouquet of red roses
that's what you're about and the more
you're about it the more the brand
strengthens now what if we make a
branding mistake and pair with the wrong
thing cuz it's going to
happen one bet pairing can absolutely
hurt a brand so if I now give my this
lovely red rose uh bouquet to my wife
and I say hey don't you love this
bouquet and she sees this rotten flower
sticking out the front she might be like
e this bouquet sucks or this brand sucks
or hey that guy got a DUI and I thought
he was this Paramount of good
ethics well that would hurt the
brain and so just like one ugly flower
messes up the whole bouquet it changes
how everyone sees the Brand This bouquet
sucks
now to recover from something like that
you just have to overwhelm customers
with the stuff they like until
eventually the bad pairing shrinks into
irrelevance so we don't try and
eliminate the DUI we don't try and
eliminate the dead row it happened
there's nothing we can do about it but
what we try to do is just overwhelm it
with way more of the stuff that the
majority of our people actually like and
so Kanye for example has said some
things that people don't
like but he also comes out with products
that people love he made a Super Bowl ad
he sold shoes
he just came out with an album that came
out after having some cancel culture
stuff around him and things he had said
and so over time people forgot the bad
stuff and Associated the good stuff back
with him and purchased they still
bought and so you need to decide what
values people experien Etc that you want
to use to connect the audience to your
product and equally importantly what
things you want to avoid remove or
ignore from the stuff they hate
and so it goes without saying that even
if you say you're premium but people
think your thing sucks that suck will
stick and so up to this point everything
I've talked about has been the things
external to the product they've been the
people you associate the product with
now almost all of that occurs prior to
purchase so you can absolutely get
someone to buy the thing but how many
experiences are people are going to have
with the thing once they've purchased it
probably far more than they have with
your advertisement
and so the advertisement can let people
know about it The Branding makes a good
Association for the person they make the
purchase and then afterwards the product
does a lot of The Branding after that
because if I buy that amazing Nike
t-shirt and there's a hole in the armpit
when it comes in I might say this is the
first time I ever bought a Nike product
this product sucks therefore Nike sucks
and then I think the whole thing is a
sham and then I also start to hate
LeBron for even recommending right
starts to transfer
backwards now on the flip side
brand can influence how people see the
product so if the product is what I
would call good enough so it's it
doesn't have any holes in it now is it
the highest quality it possibly could be
maybe not but it's good enough that no
one's going to find an immediate problem
with the product that's where brand can
carry you the extra distance to still
make it a positive experience for the
person and so brand in a very real way
can affect how people perceive value
through
products now me personally this a pro
tip here
if I'm going to charge a premium price I
absolutely want to make sure that the
product is dialed so that I only further
reinforce how much they like my brand
rather than let my brand carry me or at
worst have it conflict with the
impression that I gave them of the thing
they were going to buy prior to them
buying it this is a quote from Warren
your premium brand had better be
delivering something special or it's not
going to get the business and the only
tweak I'd have on this is it it's not
going to keep the business you'll get
the first purchase you just won't get
the ones after that
and so all the things are like okay got
it so brand is pairing I get how the
pairing makes me money I have these big
margins I got more ctrs more people buy
and as long as my thing doesn't suck and
ideally that it's good people will keep
buying awesome but how do I measure
that so braad has three main metrics one
which is influence which is How likely
it is to change someone's Behavior so if
I show someone a brand and they react in
any way they recognize it and they they
they do something about it then we have
influence second is direction are they
changing the way we wanted or are they
running
away and third how many people it
changes
for that's it so if I show room up 100
people and 100 people react versus two
people react the 100 person reacting at
least recognition that is the reach how
many people it changes it for so taking
to the hypothetical extreme a small weak
and neutral brand very few people
recognize and the people that do don't
care that much about it either way and
on the other polar extreme you have a
large large strong positive brand so
that would be lots of people recognize
the brand it changes Behavior when they
see the brand and the behavior is
generally towards so they try do in
accordance with what that brand is
asking someone to
do and I want to make this
point a lot of people have this misn
that any strong brand is polar that
because lots of people love it lots of
people o have to ha it now I say this by
percentage not necessarily by absolute
if you have if the whole United States
knows who you are you're going to have a
percentage of people that hate you just
because there's crazy people and that's
how we're talking about I'm saying is
there a brand that can't have that kind
of status that isn't polar so I'll give
a polar example first so I have the
silhouette of Donald Trump here and he
has a very strong brand he has a big
reach lots of people recognize him even
just the silhouette alone people
recognize he a strong influence as in
the percentage of people that when they
see this have a reaction in either
direction positive or negative but just
that they react shows that he has strong
influence and then third is the
direction now for him he is polar
meaning many people move towards him
very strongly and many people move away
from him very
strongly and so many assume that all
brands are that way and that's just
because there are many examples of that
but that doesn't mean it has to be that
way and so I'll give you a different
example so some Brands manage to change
change many people's behavior towards
them all at once and so like Taylor
Swift sure I'm sure she's got some
crazies don't get me wrong but the vast
majority of people who see Taylor Swift
recognize her she changed their behavior
and most of the time it's towards her so
she is a large positive strong brand
this is also personally why I think the
idea of like seeking out controversy
absolutely gets you recognized but you
don't have to make that trade you can't
absolutely just build a strong positive
brand Mother Teresa has a strong
positive brand a lot of people know her
influenced a lot of behavior did a lot
of good stuff must be work like I hate
Mother Teresa some people do but most
people don't and the same thing goes
with apple a lot of people like their
products I'm sure there are some techs
that are like Android's way better right
they're like PC is awesome and that's
great that's good for them but the vast
majority of people who encounter the
product like it which is why they're one
of the largest companies in the
world so all those examples that I gave
to you up to this point have a assumed a
large audience and I do that because
this is a pration and it makes more
sense for me to work with you on stuff
that you already know but this concept
carries independent of whether you have
large reach and this is why it applies
to you so if you had a small audience
with high influence what would you
have got Mom and Dad they are high
influence as in most people when they
see their parents their behavior
changes they have low reach because for
you they're only your parents they might
have any they might be some other
people's parents but not very many
people's parents as you have low reach
um and it will be your behavior will
towards for some and a way for others
meaning some people hate their parents
and don't want to do anything they say
and some people like their parents and
do whatever they say and there's a lot
of people in
between and so that's how we measure if
what we're doing to grow our brand is
actually working are more people finding
out about
it are more people changing their
behavior when they do it and ideally are
they doing that towards the direction
that we want them to go so if I say hey
everybody go click here go download this
thing go attend this event go buy this
product whatever it is if a lot of
people do that then we know that the
brand is
growing and so we want when we want to
build our brand we want to pair our
stuff with the things the highest
percentage of our ideal audience like
and so whenever we pair anything with a
brand because especially if you're
starting out everything is new and so
every new pairing has risk and so you
risk losing a certain percentage of your
audience who has a bad experience with
the thing you pair there's always that
risk there's always going to be some
people who don't like something you do
if anyone seen a small town band go hit
it big some of the old Towners are like
oh they sold out they did whatever but
what they did was they gambled the
short-term loss of that local audience
potentially for a much broader bigger
audience so they made a bet they did
lose people they did gain people they
just gained more than they lost and so
to the same degree when you make that
bet as the local band you risk gaining
other people who have had a positive
experience with this new thing and
ideally we have more green than red and
so those news pairings the new pairings
you make with a brand always lose
audience right he's sold out I like the
old stuff better this also happens with
content by the way and so this person is
the red bucket
fantastic and the new stuff might also
cause people to say no this new stuff
rocks and that person is in the green
bucket and so whenever you try to grow
and you make any new pairing meaning you
make new content you make a new genre
you make a new song you make a new
anything you make a bet that more people
for your ideal audience will like the
pairing than people who don't tldr that
you'll net an increase in reach
influence and positive
direction and so my ask for here is
don't let the five mean comments stop
you from Gaining the 500 new people who
like the new
thing so let me finish the real life
example to make this whole thing real
for you I want to associate myself with
business value so I associate self with
making people money and growing their
businesses so there's me there's me
making content and then ideally money
and so the best way I can do this is
make content for the small business
owner to consume and books for them to
read and use so that they then
profit the good thing and then they
associate that growth and profit with me
and so then they consume more of my
stuff they drink the next soda they buy
the next
shirt and so the next time they want it
to happen again they take the action or
they have a higher likelihood of taking
the desired action and equally important
people who don't like business stuff
won't like my stuff or they'll just
prefer to watch other things so you've
got this married couple they say we hate
people who talk about money they're
probably not going to like my stuff and
that's
okay but people
who like business have a business or
trying to start one might want more and
this grows the brand because people
consume the stuff and they say hey you
got to check out herzi stuff and then
that person they tell to says right on
they J it out they get that positive
outcome they make the pairing as well
and the brand grows and ideally with my
ideal audience and so to see this in
action if you use this information from
today to make money good branding has
occurred and so I said I was going to
cover three things what branding is IDE
what good braiding is why it makes you
money and how to start and grow yours so
hopefully you feel like I fulfilled
those three things and so now we can
test if the pairing good branding
actually
occurred so if you are my ideal customer
so here's a business owner okay awesome
a lot of you
fantastic we can see objectively if this
provided value did we get a good
positive outcome a neutral outcome or a
negative one you might be like I hate
this guy talk about money or you know
what I think this could make me a ton of
money well we'll see so I want you
further associate myself with value and
making you money and growing your
business so I going to give you guys two
gifts for
free the first is for existing business
owners who want to scale so most you
guys should raise your hands I have two
books $100 million offers $100 million
leads people say they made their money
there's a lot of five star reviews on
them fantastic and I mean video versions
of these books that you can get
absolutely free on my site at acis.com
tring this is me further associating if
you if you like this you're going to
love that and they'll make you more
money for free that's what it looks like
on the inside these are legit
courses and you can get those video
versions on my site again absolutely
free acc.com trining now if you're like
man I don't like watching stuff I like
listening to stuff I want to provide
value for a different type of Ideal
audience which is still business owners
but business owners who listen rather
than business owners who watch which is
also fine and so if you are somebody
who's not a reader or not a watcher I've
got the books on my podcast absolutely
free it's called the game they started
episode 570 something and so that's what
I have for business owners who hears
earlier on and they're like I want to
start a brand Okay cool so this is for
you so I just became a co-owner of
school.com really awesome platform helps
people get started their business um and
so anybody here who watches this or
listening to this and wants the tools
the training and a community of other
people starting brands with a little
friendly competition and some prizes we
made a step-by-step process on school to
help you get started and you can start
for
free so hopefully I succeed in providing
value and a good pairing occurred aide
good branding happened otherwise I'm
sorry everybody else I hope good bandic
occurred um and for those of you who
either start the school games for free
or use my stuff to grow your business I
will see you guys soon so go to school
games school.com games.com trining and I
will see you guys all there thank you
guys so much for your time